Kamala Harris our vice president
she has
thoughts on our culture well I think
culture is
it is a reflection of our moment and our
time right and and and
present culture is the way we express
how we're feeling about the moment
and
and we should always find times to
express how we feel about the moment
that is a reflection of Joy because
every you know
it comes in the morning
we have to find ways to also Express
the way we feel about the moment in
terms of just having language and and a
connection to how people are
experiencing life and I think about it
in that way too
culture is the Norms rituals and
behaviors of a given people
that's the answer she was looking for it
was it's just it's ninth grade English
class
when you haven't read the book
and you you are in the you're in the
honors class but you maybe you don't
belong in the honors class and you
haven't done the work anyone you said
well
you know culture where do I begin it's
you know culture is an expression of our
moment and that's and culture is
how we react to our the expression of
the moment and it's the moment and it's
joy in the morning and uh well I think
we pretty much
[Music]
yeah but do you have an answer to what
that is
no there's something really profound in
kamala's just circular and meaningless
description of culture here which is
that our culture presently is circular
and meaningless so
a keen insight about culture was given
to us by the sociologist Renee Gerard
who who pointed out that culture is
mimetic that we
human beings develop our personalities
our behaviors our language our thoughts
our desires even by imitating what we
see from other people and so a culture
that values honor is going to uh you
know let's say a monarchy traditionally
that's a culture that places a high
value on honor that culture is going to
increase in honor and in the desire for
Honor because we're all going to be
imitating each other republics
traditionally are understood as cultures
that value virtue and so they're gonna
be they're going to look different than
monarchies they're going to look
different than aristocracies and that's
going to spread too because we're going
to imitate one another the reason that
you want the nice Rolex watch is not
because you know anything about horology
or time keeping or swiss arts and crafts
it's because people that you admire and
people who you would like to be more
like want the Rolex watch that's that's
how that's how we come to this even
desire these sorts of
luxury goods that's and that would be
one of the artifacts that defines a
culture right and so all of that to say
our present culture
doesn't really value much of anything at
all
we don't value honor we don't believe in
honor anymore we don't value virtue we
don't believe in virtue anymore we don't
we do value stuff to some degree though
actually
decreasingly so if you see surveys about
Millennials and Zoomers especially we
don't really value cars anymore we don't
really value having a house anymore we
don't really value High fashion anymore
we don't even value stuff we value
nothing other than the satisfaction of
our most
animalistic desires and so human culture
starts to go away anything resembling
High culture disappears we don't have
beautiful architecture we don't have
beautiful art we don't have beautiful
music we don't have beautiful Customs or
rituals anymore it's all just kind of
base level satisfy your sexual appetite
satisfy your physical appetites not even
with
High Cuisine with kind of cheap nothing
Cuisine where we're just eating slop
basically from fast food places or from
impossible burgers or from what a soil
and milkshakes or whatever else you're
going to have so
that that's an anti-culture perfectly
expressed by Kamala Harris in this
circular rambling because we don't have
any sense of what we value anymore
because we don't have any grounding in
reality anymore and and as our society
moves further away from grounded
tangible reality into the metaverse into
virtual digital social media into the
abstraction from the self of of the self
from the body saying that our true
selves have nothing to do with our
bodies anymore as that happens the
culture is going to collapse even
further and and it's become almost
cliche now to observe that we today
could not build medieval Cathedrals we
couldn't do it we don't even know how
they were built
Notre Dame in Paris the roof burns down
we don't know how to fix it we've got
we're just gonna have to replace it with
something uglier we can't do it anymore
that culture has been lost
the apotheosis of that culture is the
incoherent rambling that you're getting
from now the vice president of the
United States right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles you know a company
is looking out for you when they
actually upgrade your service and don't
charge you for it this is great news for
new and current Pure Talk customers pure
talk just added data to every plan and
includes a mobile hotspot with no price
increase whatsoever if you've considered
pure talk before but you have not made
the switch take a look again for just
twenty dollars a month you will get
unlimited talk text and now 50 percent
more 5G data plus their new mobile
hotspot this is why I love Pure Talk
they're veteran owned and the only hire
the very best customer service team
located right here in the great us of a
most families are saving almost a
thousand dollars a year while enjoying
the most Dependable 5G Network in
America remember you vote with how you
spend your money so stop supporting woke
wireless companies that don't support
you when you go to puretalk.com Knowles
you'll save an additional 50 off your
first month because they value EU
puretalk.com Wireless for Americans by
Americans right now go to
grillblazer.com Knowles thanks to our
friends at Grill Blazer instant barbecue
Perfection is at the touch of your
fingertips Grill Blazers Grill guns are
designed to do everything from expertly
searing your Meats to lighting charcoal
grills wood stoves outdoor fireplaces
and just about anything you can think of
where you would need high power fire to
solve your problem I may or may not have
sparked up a stogie with a grill Blazer
gun you may have seen that Grill Blazers
offers two types of Grill guns the grill
gun basic is a high power propane torch
designed to Light charcoal and wood
grills and smokers burns up to 3 600
Degrees it's 30 inch flame is pretty
much all you need a big bad torch to do
and then there's the SUV gun shorter
Barrel perfect for professional Culinary
Kitchen uses from gently caramelizing
brulee or other sugars and fruits to
rapidly searing steaks outside on the
grill warning the grill gun will result
in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors right now go get the grill gun
from Grill Blazers go to grillblazer.com
Knowles use promo code nodes for 15 off
your order grillblazer.com
promo code Knowles for 15 off your order
gretathenberg was just arrested in
Sweden
she was arrested for protesting fossil
fuels or something and they arrested her
she's 20 years old now by the way they
keep pretending she's like 12 but you
know she's an adult now and she was
arrested and could be charged with a
crime and could be sentenced to six
months in prison but she won't be even
the media Outlets who are reporting on
this who are liberal and very
sympathetic to creda are saying she'll
probably just get off with a fine and
some of her big liberal backers will pay
off that fine and it won't matter at all
and she'll just go back to getting
arrested next time
that's because this protest which
presents itself as being opposed to the
system opposed to the established Powers
it is actually part of the system
protesting is part of the liberal ruling
order that's why the liberal ruling
class encouraged the BLM riots a few
years ago the riots were not in
opposition to any system they were part
of the system and protests have been
part of the system for at least 500
years I guess about 500 years of
modernity and you see that especially
kick up in something like the French
Revolution which puts modernity into
overdrive and and tears down the order
you see this in the Bolshevik Revolution
you see this uh increasingly the the
protests that tear down the edifices of
the of the old regime of the old culture
of Christendom of the West they tear
that down but they tear it down not in
spite of the liberal ruling class that
currently runs our civilization but with
the encouragement of that ruling class
because that ruling class is a liberal
ruling class that wants to tear down all
the old stuff that wants to tear down
tradition that wants to tear down the
church that wants to tear down the
family that wants to tear down the high
art that wants to tear down all the
stuff that makes us
us as a society this is also why it's
mostly futile for conservatives to
engage in the same kinds of protests and
activism that the left has been engaging
in for centuries we occasionally try to
do it and it's usually half-hearted
because it's just not really in the
conservative sensibility to take to the
streets and scream and yell in protests
like we're great at unburg or something
like that but also it's not going to
work because the system will clamp down
on us boy what a great clip that was
make sure that you
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel ring that Bell see you next time